welcome back to CBS this morning the FBI
is now involved in a massive manhunt for
a University of Connecticut senior
accused of killing two people in a
multi-state crime spree
the suspect is 23 year old Peter Mann
Fredonia police released this new photo
appearing to show him walking on train
tracks in Pennsylvania on Sunday Errol
Barnett joins us now with new details
Errol good morning good morning well
police have not yet released a motive
for these murders but it does appear
that first attack which killed a 62 year
old man was random and that's why police
are warning everyone to call 911 a and
dangerous the Connecticut State Police
are currently searching for a Peter man
Fredonia police in at least three states
swarmed multiple crime scenes
desperately searching for 23 year old
Peter man Fredonia after a weekend
filled with violence Connecticut State
Police and all of our law enforcement
partners are actively and continuously
searching for this suspect the crimes
are believed to have begun Friday when
man Fredonia allegedly attacked two men
in Willington connecticut killing 62
year-old theodore Demers authorities say
man Fredonia then broke into a home and
took the owner hostage before fleeing
with shotguns a pistol and the owners
truck man Fredonia then allegedly
traveled nearly 100 miles south to derby
connecticut where police say he killed
an acquaintance on Sunday 23-year old
Nicholas Isley and reportedly kidnapped
the man's girlfriend in a stolen vehicle
she was later found with that vehicle
safe in New Jersey police released this
photo they say shows the 23 year old
Sunday afternoon walking in East
Stroudsburg Pennsylvania near train
tracks it is the last time he was
apparently seen it's just madness
and there's nothing he can do to get out
of it he said just run for his life the
UConn senior was raised in Newtown
Connecticut less than a year ago he
posted this photo on social media in
support of Sandy Hook promise the
anti-gun violence group formed after the
2012 shooting there
the attorney for man Fredonia's family
Michael Dolan now pleading for PETA to
turn himself in Dolan telling CBS News
the suspect had been dealing with mental
health issues he had been struggling
with the anxiety and depression
he had been treated for mental health
issues for years now Matt Fredonia was
studying business and engineering at the
University of Connecticut UConn says it
is cooperating with authorities is in
contact with them and is expressing its
deepest most heartfelt sympathies to the
victims and their families Gail Erol
thank you